the british nominees are starting to
arrive here at london's
south bank and it is the most bizarre
year that the oscars has
ever seen i've certainly never covered
anything quite like this
um in la over in la at the dolby theatre
and at union station
there is a red carpet of sorts there's
only 170 guests allowed there
so it's nominees they're plus ones and
big
celebrity presenters like brad pitt and
reese witherspoon
here in london this is one of 12
international hubs happening
all around the world to ensure that
nominees can
appear in person during the ceremony
this is all happening here on london
south bank and i am delighted to say
that one of the nominees
joins me now this is um christopher
hampton
who is nominated for best um adaptive
screenplay for the father first of all
huge congratulations on your nomination
in what is the most extraordinary year
how has this experience been for you so
far
uh well it's this particular experience
this evening is certainly the way i've
been to this is the fourth oscars i've
been to i think
and it's by some an immense margin the
weirdest
uh but it's very nice to be here all the
same
as sort of important as this accolade is
well they've done they've done whatever
they can i mean it's it's actually at
the beginning
there was a uh we were sort of told if
we didn't go to la
uh we wouldn't appear at all so i think
they've made a real
when they realized that a lot of people
couldn't go to la
i think they made a tremendous effort
everyone here has had to have two
covered tests we're all being told we
have to have mass
weird distance and there's no alcohol at
the bar
most importantly it is a very different
affair isn't it
don't tell anyone we don't want you to
get chucked out at your own party
tell us about your film the father
starring sir anthony hopkins and olivia
coleman it is just
extraordinary this film isn't it uh
yes it's it's the end of a sort of long
journey that because i
i saw the play first in in france
uh about seven years ago uh and i met
florian zeller
and i decided i wanted to translate the
play and then we put the play on in
london we put it on in new york
and finally we we pushed through to
getting a film made
of it and it's been it's been the most
enormous pleasure
making the film with that fantastic cast
uh
it's been one of the most uh really
pleasurable experiences of my own career
i've had a wonderful time so this
seems like sort of unfair to get
nominated as well
good luck this evening um you've already
won one oscar so you know hopefully
another one will be added
this evening and we will be bringing you
all the winners here from the bfi
uh the london home of the oscars as and
when they happen